hi guys so you plateaued and you're
stuck and you're you want to squeeze out
more results I created this little chart
to kind of give you some ideas of what
to look at and what could be missing
because when you evaluate someone and
they're telling you I'm not getting
results I've done Kido I've done in them
and fasting it's not working for me
well I can't evaluate that unless I have
more information well instead of me
consulting you what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna show you all the common points
that always come up with people that are
kind of stuck alright so here you are
you're doing a lot of different meals in
the very beginning and this is what
people do is they're grazing every hour
and a half they have to eat if to eat
you have to eat and this is where I was
that's a certain point so what I didn't
know and what a lot of people don't know
is every time you spike insulin so we
have a lot of insulin or so the person
has a high level of insulin going on in
their blood even in a fasting state they
don't know it because they've never been
tested the doctors never even focused on
it and the blood sugars usually are
normal because that comes later because
the high levels of insulin will keep the
blood sugars down right so it won't go
up yet so they have severe insulin
resistance okay or you may have severe
insulin resistance and that's what
you're up against so the goal is to get
healthy insulin that should be your goal
okay and then that's what you should
research so what you want to do first is
learn all about it get it enough
information don't just do this half way
because you can't it doesn't work doing
it half way you have to fully understand
all the details because one little thing
could mess you up and you have to commit
to all or nothing because doing it
partial like if you do keto with that
mmm fasting it won't work if you do them
and fasting without keto it doesn't work
so there's certain guidelines that you
need to know understand learn about and
then you jump in and do it like you're
supposed to like people ask about cheat
days well that's just going to throw you
off for several days so you just want to
start off knowing what to do okay so the
step one is the three meals okay you're
probably already doing that no snacks
okay so to be able to go from one meal
to the next you need more fat that'll
help you it's more
fine you need more salad and greens so
that'll give you a potassium to heal in
for the resistance and speed things up
okay so what happens between three meals
and two meals is that's when you're
really doing a key to adaptation you're
adapting to fat in that process you're
usually going to need more of certain
nutrients you're going to need more
potassium and b1
I recommend electrolyte powder or
potassium citrate that's in it or
nutritional yeast that'll speed things
up so you won't get the side effects so
you're gonna go from here to here you're
gonna push your breakfast forward into
the point where you have two meals a day
it shouldn't be that bad so most people
can do this so now they're at two meals
a day no snacks everything's cool
now but here's the thing if you still
have cravings if you're still hungry
between the meals like excessively
you're not fully adapted so either you
got to cut your carbs lower okay keep
the carbs lower there's some hidden
carbs somewhere or you're not consuming
enough greens okay or your protein is
off a little bit so let me just kind of
quickly explain protein you know if
you're doing three meals you're doing
like maybe an average of four ounces of
protein per meal if you're doing two
meals it's like five ounces of protein
per meal if doing one meal it's about
eight ounces of protein per meal some
people want to know about calories and
grams it's extremely confusing I'm going
to tell you why but I will explain it if
you want to know so let's say for
example you have some beef okay and you
have four ounces of beef which comes out
to a hundred in 13 grams and you're
thinking oh wow
so I need 113 grams of protein per meal
no no no no this gram is for the total
weight of everything in that beef
because half of the beef is protein and
half of it is fat or maybe it's like not
exactly half and half but the point is
that this is the total the actual amount
of protein
be something like I don't know 32 grams
okay and as you look at these
nutritional facts as you if you wanted
to study it you're gonna go away wait a
second I'm counting the grams of protein
and grams of fat but they don't equal to
total what else is what else am I
missing here well what they don't
usually write in the Supplemental facts
is water water makes a big portion of
that hundred thirteen grams so in other
words don't ever look at the total grams
it's gonna confuse you okay just look at
the total grams of protein the other
thing that you can do this is a little
formula the very minimum amount of
protein you want to consume per day of
actual protein is 0.36 times your body
weight okay that will give you the
amount of protein that you need if you
really wanted to know specifically but I
don't know why you'd want because I'm
just giving you the ounces right here
but you can go between point three six
two point seven grams now per kilogram
that's a whole different unit but per
pound so you you'd multiply let's say
you weighed 200 pounds to a hundred
times point seven and that would give
you the total number of grams of protein
and that is per day not per meal okay so
it's a little confusing because we're
measuring the keto formula for certain
macronutrients and in a minute of
fasting and what's confusing for that is
as we consume less food then the amount
of protein per day is going to decrease
simply because our body's going to adapt
to conserving proteins it's going to be
more conservative of retaining more
nutrients and you're not going to need
as much food and you're gonna be fine
you're not going to become nutritionally
deficient okay but I just wanted to give
you this formula if you wanted to know
that but the point is that you could
increase or decrease your protein
depending on how you feel as well like
sometimes people feel like I had enough
protein for the day they just know they
have enough or you know what I need a
little more protein but this is kind of
like the range I would recommend now in
the very beginning when you're doing
three meals a day you're doing more fat
and you're trying to get your body in
fat-burning but I mean the goal is
really to get your body to burn its own
fat so if there's too much dietary fat
available in the diet body's not going
to necessarily go after your reserve as
much it'll go after the diet so what
does that mean it means that as you go
to two meals in one meal and you want to
lower the amount of extra of fat so I
would basically at this point if you
want to lose weight cut down the amount
of fat not by him consuming lean protein
but just don't add more fat into the
meal just keep your fat within the
protein that you normally that normally
comes with the fat and then you're going
to be okay but too much fat can slow
down your progress now the other thing
is if you're what determines whether you
go to two meals to one meal that really
has to do with your goal do you want to
lose more weight yes
okay but my metabolism is slow and it's
not working at two meals we'll just go
to one one meal that's going to really
speed things up for you to heal insulin
resistance and you're gonna see a lot
more progress because you're up against
yours of maybe a sluggish metabolism and
hormonal issues and so you're gonna have
to do something so this would be very
very important slow metabolism go to one
meal a day the other thing is you can
start focusing and reducing your stress
okay there's certain nutrients you can
take your acupressure you can go for
long walks change your environment
increase more sleep that's also gonna
help take more nutrients add more
exercise these are all things are gonna
speed things up and also look for other
body issues that you have that you can
improve for example if you have a
thyroid issue or a polycystic ovarian
syndrome or really bad cycles or
inflammatory conditions or constipation
fix the weak link okay and then that
will actually speed things up so this is
kind of my overall one chart
troubleshooter if you sort of speak to
kind of get an eyeball of what you might
be missing that you need to plug in to
achieve your goal all right
for watching subscribe sub scribe press
hey thanks for someone press the
subscribe button now I forgot what to
say I will see you in the next videos
what am I going to do subscribe to the
press button and oh yeah send you
additional information press the
subscribe button and I will keep you
updated on the future events